sehr geehrte Damen und Herren herzlich
willkommen zur Pressekonferenz
anlässlich airper
202 mein Name ist Georg Hertinger ich
komme von derektion Kommunikation aus
dem Bundesministerium für
Landesverteidigung und werde bei der
airp der Leiter des Medienzentrums sein
ich darf Ihnen das Podium hier kurz
vorstellen unsere
Verteidigungsministerin Magister Claudia
Tanner Landeshauptmann Christoph
drechlerubupmann Landtagsabgeordneter
Hannes schwarz Alexander Steirer
Marketingleiter bei Red Bull
Österreich Mirko fleim Chefpilot
Helikopter flying
buuls Brigadier Gottfried Bromberger
erdschff der Österreichischen
Luftstreitkräfte und neben mir Brigadier
Wolfgang preler Projektleiter der airper
2024 und nicht am Podium ich möchte
trotzdem begrüßen den Militärkommandant
von der von Steiermark
Herr
zölner fr
Bundesminister Bundesminister ich darf
um ihre Worte ja vielen Dank sehr
geehrter Herr Landeshauptmann sehr
geehrter Herr klubopmann Herr Marketing
Leiter steer Herr Chefpilot von unserem
Partner Red Bull erdschiifbgadier
Bromberger und natürlich vor allem am
heutigen Tag auch sehr geehrter Herr
Projektleiter Brigadier brer sehrte
Damen und Herren der Medien ich weiß
nicht wie es ihn ergangen ist als wir
jetzt schon
mit beobachten dürften und erste
Einblicke auch bekommen durften einen
Vorgeschmack das war schon irgendwie ein
besonderes grippeln dass da jetzt da war
als wir die Vorführung zweier Alpha
chetz der Flying Bulls mit verfolgen
durften be perfektem Wetter und zwei
unserer Eurofighter auch sehen konnten
es daort nicht mehr ganz ein Jahr am 6
und 7 September
2024 werden wir vom österreichischen
Bundesheer gemeinsam mit unserem Partner
mit dem Land Steiermark Herr
Landeshauptmann und mit Red Bull hier am
Flieger Horst hinterstußer in Zeltweg
die airp 24 durchführen die airp 24 wird
das verschiedenen Elementen bestehen es
ist eine militärische Leistungsschau am
Boden zu erwarten Vorführungen der
österreichischen luftstreikkräfte und
internationaler militärischer Kunstflug
Staffeln sowie der fing red Bus aber
auch teilnehmen aus dem Bereich der
Zivilluftfahrt einer statischen schau
auch von zivilen Ausstellern aus den
Bereichen der Luftfahrtindustrie aber
auch der Forschung und der Lehre und es
wird auch eine sehr umfangreiche
Rahmenveranstaltungen Flugplatzgelände
geben inklusive dem Militär
Luftfahrtmuseum das ist uns auch ganz
besonders wichtig wichtig ist auch dass
auch heuer wieder die teilen bzw
nächstes Jahr die Teilnahme an der
Airpower 24 für die Besucherinnen und
Besucher kostenlos sein wird unsere
Luftstreitkräfte sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren werden sowohl am Boden als auch
in der Luft einen besonderen Beitrag
leisten und die Besucherinnen und
Besucher werden sich aus erster Hand
einen Eindruck verschaffen können wozu
unsere Luft Streitkräfte im Stande sind
und insbesondere auch was wir an in den
nächsten Jahren an neuen Luftfahrzeugen
äh bekommen werden es wird unter anderem
ein
displaybeitrag der Transportflugzeuge
c390 zu sehen sein
flugdemonstrationen möglicher Nachfolger
für unsere SAB 105 die wir ausscheiden
mussten die aktuell ebenfalls im Zuge
des aufbauplanes 2032 beschafft werden
wird und es wird doch erstmals der neue
meerzwe Hubschrauber AW 1669 m leihern
in einem Flying Display zu sehen sein
was aber die Air Power 24 vor allem sein
soll ist ein Event für die ganze Familie
es wird auch insbesondere für Kinder
abwechslungsreiche Unterhaltungen
großartiges Rahmenprogramm geben und was
neu ist
erstmalig bis zwei Stunden nach dem
Programm also ein beiden Tagen bis 19
Uhr besondere Programme geboten werden
die Schwerpunkte wird dann das
Projektteam insbesondere unser
Projektleiter Brigadier brilla auch
näher erzählen es wird ein neues
Verkehrskonzept geben wir werden unser
Nachhaltigkeitskonzept mit einer
weiteren Verbesserung der CO2 Bilanz
sowie einer nahe zuu 100ertprozentigen
Wertschöpfung in der Region in den
Bereichen Catering Gastronomie und
Versorgung anbieten können auch dazu
werden sie noch Näheres hören ich freue
mich und es ist an dieser Stelle Zeit
ein Dankeschön zu sagen dir Herr
Landeshauptmann aber auch dem Herrn
Bürgermeister seitens des Landes auch
dir Herr klubopmann als Partner des
Landes Steiermark und insbesondere auch
an Red Bull gerichtet dass wir und das
möchte ich besonders betonen gerade in
wirtschaftlich herausfordernden
schwierigen Zeiten mit der Airpower 24
in dieser Region einen unglaublich
wichtigen Impuls geben und setzen werden
vielen vielen Dank dafür und ich darf
damit schon an dich her Landes haupmann
übergeben ja sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin
F Herr Klubobmann Herr Bürgermeister
Liebe Vertreter des Bundesheers und vor
allem auch liebe Vertreter von Red Bull
ich darf mich ganz herzlich bedanken ich
Stör den dank gleich an die Spitze ich
bedanke mich
dafür dass wir
2024 wiederum eine Airpower hier in
Zeltweg durchführen können und ich bin
außerordentlich glücklich dass wir den
Rhythmus wieder verkürzen konnten und zu
einem zweijährigen Rhythmus sozusagen
zurückkehren das ist sehr erfreilich die
Airpower ist wohl neben Formel 1 und
MotoGP am RedBull Ring das größte Event
in der steuermark und ist natürlich für
diese Region von entscheidender
Bedeutung eigentlich für die Steiermark
von entscheidender Bedeutung und
deswegen sind wir als Land Steiermark
gerne wieder Partner gemeinsam mit dem
österreichischen Bundesheer und Red Bull
denn ich glaube wenn man einmal eine
Airpower hier auf diesem Gelände erlebt
hat dann weiß man dass das eine
Veranstaltung ist die einfach Massen
anzieht die sich in die Herzen der
Menschen gespielt hat weil es ein
derartig großes Interesse gibt dass man
einfach
nur glücklich sein kann wenn diese
Veranstaltung wieder stattfindet
daher mein ganz großer Dank an Red Bull
denn
äh was der gebürtige steirerdrich
matischitz Grund gelegt hat wird in
exzellenter Manier fortgesetzt nämlich
eine ganz besonders enge Zusammenarbeit
hier in der steiermarkt das trifft
einerseits den Red Bull Ring und alles
was damit zu tun hat
danke Wolf und das ist natürlich auch
hier bei der Airpower von entscheidender
Bedeutung insofern es hat uns tief
beeindruckt diese kurze Vorführung heute
und da hat wir auch schon gesehen wie
eng verzahnt Bundesheer und Red Bull bei
dieser Veranstaltung sind dafür recht
herzlichen Dank ja ich
glaube ich glaube aber dass es neben dem
dass das wirklich eine Veranstaltung für
die ganze Familie ist es auch von
entscheidender Bedeutung ist das
österreichische Bundesheer sein Gerät
und seine Leistungen und seine
exzellenten Piloten und Pilotinnen in
den Mittelpunkt zu stellen denn ich
glaube dass es gerade in dieser Zeit
wichtig ist in einer Zeit in der wir uns
plötzlich besinnen müssen dass das
Bundesheer nicht nur eine nette
Katastrophen Schutz Hilfsorganisation
ist sondern Militär ist im engeren
Wortsinn und da halte ich es auch für
sehr wichtig dass wir das Bundesheer und
insbesondere die Luftstreitkräfte hier
auch in einen öffentlichen in ein
öffentliches Licht rücken und eine
öffentliche Darstellung der Fähigkeiten
und Möglichkeiten hier machen in diesem
Sinne meine sehr vererehrten Damen und
Herren Namens des Landes Steiermark
freue ich mich wirklich außerordentlich
dass wir hier wieder gemeinsam diese
Airpower 2024 auf die Beine stellen bzw
in die Luft
bringen ich darf den Herrn
Landtagsabgeordneten Klubobmann Hannes
Schwarz und seine Worte bitten ja
schönen Vormittag auch von meiner Seite
meine sehr verhrten Damen und Herren ich
kann mich dem Gesagten im Grunde dem
bisher Gesagten im Grunde nur
anschließen ich glaube es ist eine
wichtige Veranstaltung für das
österreichische Bundesheer es ist eine
tolle Veranstaltung für Luftfahrt
enthusiastinnen und Enthusiasten für
ganze Familien wir haben wir bereits
einen Einblick in in in das was möglich
ist im Rahmen dieser heutigen Vorführung
erhalten ist wirklich toll bei so
schönen Wetter diese tollen Piloten zu
erleben diese tollen Luftfahrzeuge zu
erleben und insofern freut es mich sehr
dass diese erbau jetzt auch im nächsten
Jahr wieder stattfindet der
landeshaupmann die Frau Bundesminister
haben sie bereits erwähnt ist wichtig
für die Region ist wichtig für die
Wertschöpfung in dieser Region ist
wichtig für die Arbeitsplätze in dieser
Region ist wichtig für den Tourismus in
dieser Region und insofern glaube ich
dass wir sagen können alle Partner und
Partner dieser Veranstaltung profitieren
voneinander und es ist eine tolle Sache
dass sie jetzt auch wieder regelmäßig
stattfindet in diesem Sinne danke
vielmals danke mich bedanke mich beim
Bundesheer bedanke mich bei Red Bull und
allen anderen Partnern und Partnern dass
diese tolle Veranstaltung weiterhin in
der steuermark stattfindet herzlichen
Dank ich darf den Marketingleiter von
Red Bull Österreich Alexander Steirer um
seine Worte bitten ja schönen Vormittag
auch von meiner Seite sehr geehrte Dame
sehr Gerte Herren Werte Partner
m die Vorfreude auf die Airpower steigt
wenn man heute in der Früh die
Vorführung gesehen hat dann wissen wir
wofür die Airpower steht wenn man sich
das Wort genauer betrachtet Airpower
luftkraft dann steht Luft für das
fliegerische und das fliegerische und
die Passion die damit verbunden ist ein
uns als Partner und motiviert uns dass
wir gemeinsam diese Veranstaltung auf
die Beine stellen auf der anderen Seite
ist das Wort power Kraft und da fällt
mir zunächst einmal die Anziehungskraft
ein die Anziehungskraft die diese
Veranstaltung ausübt und die knapp
300.000 Leute in die schöne Steiermark
holt aus Österreich und darüber hinaus
und zum anderen ist noch das Wort Kraft
auch die Strahlkraft und die Strahlkraft
also die Außenwirkung dieser
Veranstaltung es sind die Helden der
Lüfte und die wunderschönen Bilder rund
herum die in die ganze Welt hinausgehen
und als die bedeutendste Airpower
Europas
auch in Europa wirklich äh zahlreich in
den Medien wiederzufinden sind sowohl in
den traditionellen Medien und hier auch
ein Dank an die Medienvertreter und
natürlich auch in den sozialen Medien
und dadurch können wir auch neue
Zielgruppen für diese besondere
Veranstaltung gewinnen wir freuen uns
natürlich auch auf die fliegerischen
darbittungen der flyingpols ihre
internationalen Freunde da kommt der
Mirko in der Folge noch genauer darauf
zusprechen und wir freuen uns natürlich
auch wieder auf die weiteren Highlights
wie z.B auch das leiseste Highlight der
Airpower die planex der spiegelflugteam
in diesem Sinne wie gesagt die Vorfreude
steigt auch der Respekt vor dieser
Veranstaltung es ist auch äh viel zu tun
in der weiteren Folge da freuen wir uns
dass wir das gemeinsam mit unseren
Partner machen in diesem Sinne danke für
die gute Partnerschaft und ähm
ja sie
haben
sie haben den Chefpiloten Helikopter
flying plls angesprochen Mirko fleim
bitte ja guten Tag
auch wir von den fly bullz freuen uns
extrem auf auf die Erbauer 24
wir blicken Heu auf einer Airshow
saaison zurück mit ungefähr 60 Events
und Airshows in ganz Europa und
international und uns freut umso mehr zu
wissen dass wir wieder zu Hause
mit so tollen Partnern mitwirken können
um die Erbauer wieder ganz speziell zu
machen wie schon erwähnt wir haben ein
bisschen alles dabei unsere Flotte an
an historischen Luftfahrzeugen
Hubschraubern und eben bis zu den
leisesten
Segelfliegern also ja wir freuen uns
sehr dabei wieder mitwirken zu
dürfen ich spricht jetzt zu ihnen der
erdschff der österreichischen
luftstitkräfte Brigadier herfed brberger
Frau Bundesministerin Herr
landeshaupmann geschätzte
Medienvertreter die abauer 24 ist der
keineswegs eine Veranstaltung rein der
Luftstreitkräfte sondern sie umfasst im
Prinzip alle Bereiche des
österreichischen bundesjahres und
natürlich auch der Zentralstelle des
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
alle beteiligten Verbände der Land und
luftschreitkräfte werden mit einer
profunden Vorbereitung die bereits jetzt
eingesetzt hat die Voraussetzung für
eine beispiellos grße
Großveranstaltung nämlich die Europas
größte Airshow mit wie bereits erwähnt
ca 300.000 Besuchern und Besucherinnen
schaffen aber das möchte doch auch
erwähnen auch die Miliz und die Sanität
sowie auch die Logistik des östischen
Bundesheeres stellt bei der abauer
stellt die Abau einen sehr sehr hohen
ausbildungswert da eine echte Premiere
bei der airber 24 wird wiederum ein
flying Display des österreichischen
Bundesheeres sein mit
erstmals über 25 Luftfahrzeugen
gleichzeitig in einem Display wo alle
leistungspekt in der luftschittkräfte
gezeigt werden und die ist eingebunden
in eine entsprechend dramaturgische
Inszenierung mit einem speziell dafür
komponierten Musik die von über 100
MusikerInnen und Musikerin von den
österreichischen von der
österreichischen Militärmusik
eingespielt werden wird damit wird aber
auch den luftschkräften mit der
methodees kreativen inszenierten
großraumtheaters auch impliziert
einerseits die Inhalte des aufbauplans
öphh 2032 Plus und natürlich auch die
Ziele die unsere Frau Bundesminister
vorgegeben hat im Zuge der Mission
vorwärts entsprechend kommuniziert wir
sind zur airbauer oder zumindest Z
airbau hab bis jetzt airbau 24 B als
erstchief
30 Einladungen an befreundete
ausländische luftschittkräfte zu teil
versendet darüber hinaus werden noch um
die 25 zivile Airshow Teams teilnehmenn
aus 10 Nationen insgesamt erwarte ich
neben den Beiträgen wie bereits erwähnt
der Flying Puls und den östch
luftschkräften bei der airb 24 sowohl
beim static bis Display auch auch beim
flying Display also sprich beim
Flugprogramm spektakuläre und noch nie
da gewesene Highlights und das gesamte
Programm zur
24 wird dann im ersten Halbjahr 2024
präsentiert werden
und unser Projektleiter der airbauer 24
Brigadier Wolfgang brieler wird ihen nun
einige Details zum aktuellen
Planungsstand präsentieren danke
sehr ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
auch von meiner Seite herzliches
Willkommen
ich darf Ihnen sagen dass die
Projektorganisation gemeinsam mit dem
Partnern Red Bull und auch dem Land
Steiermark die Projektorganisation
aufgestellt haben wir arbeiten zurzeit
bereits auf Hochdruck und es ist mir
wirklich eine eine Freude Ihnen hier
einige Einblicke in den derzeitigen
Planungsstand zu geben das erste was ich
es sagen möchte das ist ein mal
ansprechen möchte das ist das
Verkehrskonzept das nimmt einen
besonderen
einen besonderen Stellenwert in der
Planung jetzt ein wir werden bei der
airbauer 24 den öffentlichen Verkehr
noch weiter er Höhen wir werden aus den
Landeshauptstädten Sonderzüge an beiden
Veranstaltungstagen hier herkommen
lassen wir werden dabei aber
gleichzeitig versuchen den den den
Bahnhof Zeltweg zu entlasten und die
Bahnhöfe Judenburg und und Knittelfeld
verstärkt verstärkt einbinden und von
diesen beiden Bahnhöfen Judenburg und
Knittelfeld dann in einem permanenten
schuttelbetrieb diese buschuttelbetrieb
die Bevölkerung die Zuschauer hier auf
das veranstalt
Gelände bringen des Weiteren wird werden
wir auch zusätzlich noch
Buslinien haben zumindest 300 an denen
planen wir jetzt aus verschiedenen
verschieden Gebieten aus Österreich um
hier den öffentlichen Verkehr zu
verstärken
und und hier das auch im Summe zu
entlasten wir sind
auch dabei und unterstützen auch die die
die die Planungen der Gemeinde Zeltweg
hier dem den Bahnhof
den Bahnhof Steig zu den den den den
gleissteig zu verlängern gemeinsam mit
mit mit Red Bull
die Frau Bundesminister hat es bereits
angesprochen was auch neu sein wird
bisher war es so noch Ende des
flugprogramms sind und alle Besucher
haben das Veranstaltung
Veranstaltungsgelände verlassen das
versuchen wir jetzt zu verlängern von 17
bis 19 Uhr wir werden attraktives
Programm haben wir werden Militärmusik
sehen können wir haben einige
Sportveranstaltungen und Vorführungen
die wir hier haben um dann das die
Bevölkerung hier noch am Platz zu haben
und nicht dass alle gleichzeitig das
Veranstaltungsgelände verlassen und so
diesen Stau etwas zu
minimieren im großen muss man aber schon
eine eines sagen
wir hier in die Gemeinde zeltwg hat 7000
Einwohner und wir haben pro Tag
150.000 Besucher die hier auf das fah
staltungsgelände strömen 150.000
Besucher das ist die Einwohnerzahl der
Stadt Salzburg und das muss man
berücksichtigen und es ist natürlich
eine große Herausforderung das zu zu zu
organisieren und das daran sind wir auch
daran hier das noch weiter zu verbessern
ein weiterer wichtiger Punkt für uns in
der Planung das ist die Nachhaltigkeit
wir haben im letzten Jahr hier ein
wirklich gutes Konzept erarbeitet wir
haben gemein mit
Experten unseres Hauses aber auch
Experten der der zivilwirtschaft hier
ein Konzepte arbeitet und durch darf
Ihnen sagen im Vergleich zu
2019 haben wir
2022 ein ein eine CO2 Bilanz von -1% pro
Besuche erreicht das ist wirklich ein
tolles Ergebnis und das werden wir auch
weiter forsieren durch auch dieses
Verkehrskonzept ist neue den
öffentlichen Verkehr zu intensivieren
ein des Opfer
wirrtschaftskonzept durchzusetzen und
auch hier in weiterer Folge das weiter
zu äh
optimieren was die CO2 Bilanz betrifft
und abschließend bitte möchte ich noch
eines hier sagen die Airpower ist keine
Übung oder nicht nur eine Übung das ist
ein wirklicher Einsatz
und was auf anhb funktionieren muss das
ist einfließen verschiedener
verschiedenster Kunstflugteams aus
verschiedenen Staaten hier muss es eine
enge Kooperation geben höchste
Professionalität unseres Personals hier
vor Ort die Flugsicherheit ist oberstes
Gebot es muss vorgeübt werden aber nicht
nur das es ist die flughoffenfeuerwehr
der militärmologische Dienst alles das
muss hier zusammenspielen um eine
sichere erfolgreiche airbauer
durchführen zu können meine Damen und
Herren ich und mein Team wir freuen uns
wirklich sehr auf die Aufgabe wir freuen
uns auf die Herausforderung und ich
freue mich schon wirklich auf eine tolle
Veranstaltung am 67 September 2024 hier
in
Zeltweg im Murtal danke
schön sehr gehte Damen und Herren sie
haben jetzt die Möglichkeit Fragen an
die Referenten zu
stellen bitte Kollege
Kolon den Herren von militäris
beantworten möchte welches milizbaton
lustig jägerbon ein Wien jägerbatillon 1
Wien okay und dann eine Frage an die
Politik wie schaut's mit den Kosten aus
ist es wieder die Drittelung und was
macht's gesamt aus ich nehme an es wird
einiges an Steigerungen geben nachdem
alles in Österreich teurer geworden ist
es ist wieder eine Drittelung daher auch
ein Dankeschön an die Partner pro
Partner ,4 Millionen
Euro bleibt jetzt künftig bei der zwei
Jahresrhythmus und warum ist man auf den
jetzt wieder umgestiegen der Herr
Landeshauptmann hat angesprochen jawohl
das war die Entscheidung dass wir das
alle zwei Jahre wieder in diesem
regelmäßigen Rhythmus auch machen die
Begründung ist eine relativ einfache
weil es sehr gut angenommen wird von der
Bevölkerung was wirtschaftlich für die
Region etwas bringt und weil es für uns
als österreichisches Bundesheer mehr ist
so wie vorhin schon angesprochen als ein
großartiger Tag sondern auch Übung
Einsatz und ich bin wirklich froh dass
man diesen neuen Rhythmus oder den alten
Rhythmus wieder gefunden hat weil das
was die Frau Bundesministerin sagt ist
ja eindrucksvoll unterstrichen worden
bei der letzten Airpower was den Besuch
und was die Organisation der
Veranstaltung betroffen
hat ja Schlach mein Name für ATV und bis
und logisti ich hätte an die Politik
eine Frage zuerst an den Herrn
Landeshauptmann wie gedenken Sie die
Airpower auch für eine nachhaltige
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung hier in der
Steiermark zu nutzen ziehen Sie dann
versuchen Sie vielleicht Unternehmen
hier anzuziehen und das zweite an die
Frau
Bundesministerin genau auch in Bezug auf
die Airpower es gibt ja auch Dinge wo
man
sagen muss dass man ins Bundesheer mehr
investieren muss wir haben eine andere
Sicherheitslage wie wird sich das hier
auf diesen Standort auswirken wird hier
mehr
investiert nun es hat ja bereits 2022
bei der Airpower eine entsprechende
wirtschaftliche Leistungsschau auch
gegeben Luftfahrttechnik ist ja im
Rahmen des mobilitätsklasters in der
steuermark eine Industrie die für die
Steiermark auch von großer Bedeutung
ist passt auch gut zum Forschungs und
Entwicklungsland Nummer 1 zur
Innovationsregion Nummer 1 in Österreich
und insofern gibt's diesen nachhaltigen
Effekt durch eine enge Verzahnung
einer solchen Veranstaltung mit der
entsprechenden Industrie in der
steermark ich bedanke mich für die Frage
weil äh es über Jahrzehnte so war dass
man das österreichische Bundesheer
budgetär unglaublich vernachlässigt hat
was zu den ja bekannten Folgen geführt
hat zum Zeitpunkt meines amtsantrittes
vor jetzt 3 Jahren und 10 Monaten habe
ich irgendwie so scherzhaft gesagt Beier
jedes Gerät in im Ressort ist älter als
ich ich bin bauah 1970 ähm wir haben
erkannt dass das notwendig ist von
Anbeginn an meiner Amtszeit es hat eine
dreimalige budgeterhöhung gegeben aber
die unglaublich fordernde
Sicherheitslage nicht zuletzt dann mit
Beginn des Angriffs Krieges Putins auf
der Ukraine hat dazu geführt dass wir
das höchste Verteidigungsbudget haben
das wir jemals hatten das heißt 16
Milliarden Euro die wir investieren
werden allein in den nächsten vier
Jahren in den drei Bereichen die zum
einen einmal die Mobilität anbelangt
natürlich in der Luft wir werden da
einiges ja bei der airpow auch sehen
unseren neuen Hubschrauber den Lein ab
169 m von den wir 36 Stück dann auch
bekommen werden es ist
selbstverständlich eine Investition auch
in unsere Eurofighter notwendig die wir
auf den Weg gebracht haben das heißt
dann auch hier für den für diesen Stand
Standort selbstverständlich eine sehr
wichtige Investition das ist die
Mobilität in der Luft aber wir
investieren selbstverständlich auch in
die Mobilität auf der Straße am Boden
wenn man nur daran denkt dass wir über
850 LKWs beschaffen werden auch hier
wieder jeder Euro ist einer der in die
Sicherheit der Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher investiert wir aber
durchaus auch in die Wirtschaft in die
österreichische Wirtschaft ja und der
dritte Bereich das ist der unsere
soldatinen Soldaten das Wichtigste das
wir haben ausmacht die entsprechende
Ausstattung auch beginnend von den
Uniformen mit der entsprechenden
Bewaffnung mit dem entsprechenden
Kommunikationsgerät auch ausgerüstet und
das noch abgesichert auf die nächsten 10
Jahre wir haben einen Aufbauplan der
reicht bis ins Jahr 2032 und darüber
hinaus es ist wichtig dass wir auch
transpar
zeigen das ganze ist in einem Gesetz
fixiert im
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
alljährlich legen wir auch den Parlament
das ist einmal schon passiert
Rechenschaft darüber ab was haben wir
bereits beschafft auf welche Art und
Weise haben wir das getan und was werden
wir noch tun ich glaube das ist wichtig
weil es immerhin um sehr viel Steuergeld
geht aber wie gesagt jeder Euro den wir
hier investieren ist einer in unser
aller
Sicherheit weitere Fragen
luäftenzw wie bereits erwähnt ich hab 30
erdschiffs einen Brief geschrieben bin
mit vielen natürlich persönlich auch in
Kontakt es gibt natürlich schon
informelle
Zusagen der Planungsprozess ist d mit
Ende ersten Quartal 24 abgeschlossen und
dann unser Team um den displaydirektor
Thomas bloder wird dann wieder ein
wunderbares vom Programm zaubern
zwischen immer eine tolle Abwechslung
zwischen Zivil Militär Mirko und Alex
hat schon erwähnt von Segelfliegern bis
zu etwas lauteren Flugzeugen aber es
gibt schon zusagen aber wie gesagt
eine eine endag so eine end
Zusammenfassung wird mit Ende März 24
erfolgen
Sicherheitslage in
Europa zu bekommen oder ist man da
zurück na also anfü sich es hat bis dato
mit den erdschiffs denen ich gesprochen
habe das war Deutschland Schweiz Italien
Dänemark Frankreich um nur einige zu
nennen hat's durchaus sehr sofort sehr
sehr positive für Signale gegeben also
die Notwendigkeit die Leistungsfähigkeit
der luftschutkräfte und darüber hinaus
darzustellen ist jem erdschiff durus
bewusst um auch der entsprechend der
Bevölkerung auch in das
Leistungsspektrum in den
Sicherheitsgefühl entsprechend
darzustellen es war Rüben noch eine
Frage
Frau Bundesministerin her landeshupmann
sie haben den Verkehr
angesprochen es gibt soweit ich richtig
informiert war oder es gab zumindestens
mal eine Diskussion über den Ausbau der
lavantalbahn zwischen
koralbahn und Zeltweg die dies
Lückenschluss zu machen um auch den
öffentlichen Verkehr und generell den
Verkehr in Richtung Zeltweg auszubauen
wie lauft es dirit gibt's da überhaupt
noch Debatten Diskussion mit dem
zuständigen Ministerium oder wie schaut
das
aus ja danke für die gestellte Frage es
ist so dass der Ausbau des Bahnsteigs
Zweg der Ausbau des Bahnsteigs Zeltweg
natürlich eine essentielle ist und da
bitten wir natürlich und ich weiß wir
haben schon Gespräche geführt ich weiß
auch von Red Bull dass das positive
Signale gibt was denn die
bahnsteigverlängerung ausmacht und ich
hoffe dass wir da was zusammenbringen
wichtig ist natürlich dass wir die ÖBB
mit ins Brot natürlich nehmen und da
hoffe ich dass es demnächst Gespräche
gibt positive Gespräche weil ich glaube
jede Großveranstaltung die wir im Murtal
haben kann natürlich von Zeltweg aus zu
Fuß erreicht werden ob das jetzt die
Formel 1 die MotoGP oder MD Abau ist und
da würden wir dringendst die
bahnsteigverlängerung brauchen das sind
50 m glaub 25 m auf der Westseite und
Ostseite jeweils und das wäre natürlich
eine ganz tolle Sache für die Region für
die Wirtschaft und dann wäre auch diese
Anbindung an die lavandalbahn natürlich
auch gegeben weil es ist Zeltweg ein
Verkehrsknotenpunkt es war immer ein
Verkehrsknotenpunkt und es wäre ganz
ganz wichtig und ich hoffe dass wir bald
die Gespräche mit der öpb auch führen
können weil die brauchen wir n nicht im
Boot ich glaube wir sind uns da einig
das bundeser wir haben da einen guten
Austausch in den tollen und Red Bull
natürlich da bin ich dankbar weil sehr
viele Projekte in Zeltweg aber auch in
der Region passiert sind und da hoffe
ich dass wir zusammen kommmen jetzt
brauchen wir da die ÖBB das ist ja
unteres Ministerium das weiß ich und ich
hoffe dass wir da was zusammenbringen
[Applaus]
danke sehr gerne ich gehe ja davon aus
dass alle Interesse haben unsere
Bemühungen zu verstärken gerade im
nachhaltigkeitsbereich was das
Verkehrskonzept anbelacht anbelangt ein
Dankeschön auch an unseren Partner Red
Bull stellvertretend an Dich lieber
Alexander aber auch an an all diejenigen
die zu ihrem Wort stehen ebenfalls an
dich Herr Bürgermeister ein ganz großes
Dankeschön und wir gehen davon aus dass
die Entscheidung alsbald fällt so dass
wir auch dann die die das entsprechende
Verkehrskonzept am Bahnsteig so leben
können wie das im Sinne der
Nachhaltigkeit auch Sinn macht nicht nur
für die airp sondern für die vielen
Veranstaltungen die es ja hier im Land
gibt Frau Bundesminister sehr geehrte
Herren Medienvertretern bedanke mich
ebenfalls und damit die
Pressekonferenz
gut